boo boo boo you came into my life and
the world never look so bright it is you
you bring out the best of me when you
are
[Applause]
you know you guys obviously have become
fast family you know you and the rest of
the guys I mean are you guys get on each
other's nerves yet though have you got
that here's the thing when you become
family you a bounty come on you I didn't
if you got siblings but I'm a co-worker
I love to drive you insane yeah but on
the whole you love them and that's the
lovely thing about what we have here we
fight like family but we make up like
family and we are always there for each
other which is lovely yeah you know it's
funny because when we talk to the
Backstreet Boys recently they admitted
that they actually do group therapy
because it's like you know they've been
together for so long so it hasn't gotten
there yet here's the thing we do not
need that let me tell you why oh I can't
I am British
we are not like Americans we state as it
is right and so that means that we saw
that Robinson also I don't if you know
this you guys
we share a trailer we're not like any
other show because we film in the middle
of nowhere we don't have space but five
trailers we share a trailer so there are
problems you solve them real fast real
fast real rough I'm not harboring any
feelings they come out no that's that we
come off again we solve it a heartbeat
because we know okay I've got to be with
this person for months and months month
in one trailer yeah what's been the
biggest thing you guys have fought about
oh gosh what I did we last fight about
probably lateness did you have to wait
Reacher I mean you guys can't start
until everyone's there yeah we're all
terrible at it so yes we'll fight with
each other about latest but then the
next day the person who starts the
argument is also late we're not great at
that we are always tardy yeah so you
guys wrap season three I mean how
different was this experience now that
you guys are kind of household names you
know shooting season it was very
difficult to would go out because we are
out filming in real locations nobody
cared before would they didn't know who
we were now trying to go out and
probably could shoot a show it was hard
like and out a scene that would take an
hour before would take five because
everyone's hounding you it's just you're
in the middle of a scene and somebody
comes over but they don't see the
cameras in the distance can we take a
selfie while cooking like you're
literally in my shot like we're filming
a show right now right now dude was it
different with the men and or women that
you guys made over to were they I don't
know a bit more willing to in
trustworthy now
no really was nervous I I can't imagine
if let's say for example okay Debra
Messing's here today great from all in
grace
if Debra Messing turned off and was like
hey it's when I talk to you for two
hours
I'd be nervous if you know that person
and you are a fan of that person that's
nerve-racking and so the first day
actually was so much harder this season
than it was last year because they they
knew who we were or more nerve-racking
were really response truck baby yeah a
little bit and that was bizarre
especially when Jonathan Van Ness is
coming at you you know a lot of energy
coming your way real quick how would you
sum up 2018 and one sound no words a
sound
[Music]